please shine your flood lamp outside of
scp-087 to verify it's functioning
properly thank you please continue to
the first landing please continue to the
first landing as per our earlier
conversation please continue to the
first landing please remove one of the
adhesive lights and a fix it to the wall
on the landing that's unconfirmed please
our fix an adhesive light to the wall
and verify it functions please turn off
your flood lamp thank you
you may turn your flood lamp back on
please continue to descend at each
landing please a fix an LED light to the
wall turn it on if you notice anything
unusual please report it can you still
hear the previously reported audio
please place the light to continue down
to leave notice anything unusual
I don't think I'll get another closer to
the kid look how far below would you
estimate the source of the sound to be
sales before 150 200 meter thank you
please proceed you see that yes can you
please describe what you see
who's that son / to the wall and step
over here's all / mark looks really
smooth yeah smooth feels like thank you
please continue down please continue as
per our agreement I don't want to be
doing this I feel like the case you
straddle me down I think it's traffic
meeting is there a reason you stopped
d-9035 can you hear me
please slow down
[Music]
you